[Applause]
let's wash that awesomeness down with
some final rebel beauty junkie time i'm
so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram goddess me and jan
bye okay i have to
we've met actually we've met this is a
very surreal moment for me
first of all you're bringing and wearing
my one of my very favorite eye
um artistry jobs on your instagram that
i've come through we hand-picked all the
images in fact i want to just
show an example of there's that look
live
and in person one of my favorites and
the next one
is i just love how listen
these can go really wrong they can and
look at how subtle
playful and beautiful and you did that
tutorial with your fingers and then
these flames
for those who love flames somehow you
make
really rebellious makeup look wearable
and that is an art how do you do it how
do i do it
i like to play with a lot of color
obviously on the eyes
but then i keep the skin very natural
and i don't go
too heavy with smokiness i do love a
smokey eye
but i think that like you can balance
things out really well and i even though
it is bold it's very vibrant
i think it's still very fresh so i keep
the skin fresh i keep the skin dewy
i keep the eyebrows pretty natural so
that the eyes are kind of the focus and
nothing's ever too
precious or perfect about it kind of has
a wabi-sabi kind of imp imperfect
kind of look i love wabi-sabi and we met
because i was always talking about
flower beauty with you
yes well you started with fire29 and i
interviewed you once
and i was a producer on a show that you
were
interviewed on too well i thank you for
taking the time so i could get the word
out because when we launched flower
beauty it was like the
birth of instagram and social media and
influencers and it was a really wild
time
it was also the time when makeup was
getting very garish and
into the artistry and very heavy and
you're absolutely right the fact that
you balance a dewy natural look
with these poppy eyes i think is the way
to be able to sport it and look like an
artist and not an insane person
yeah but it's kind of like do whatever
makes you feel
good i mean i think a lot of people see
my looks and they're like that's crazy
i would never wear that and i'm gonna
like totally wear it in fact
everybody go to our website because our
news crew
member catherine is actually going to
get made up by man and man's going to
teach us some tutorials on how you
can live a more playful expressionist
life me and thank you for being here so
much
that's true in a minute
[Music]
you